[Music]
these streets are no longer under
Russian control
but they're still in firing range
imagine having to get used to this
[Music]
it's the reality of Russia's war with
Ukraine having to fight to win back its
land
but not everyone's a fan how are you
feeling living in the middle of all this
chaos
she sarcastically thanks Ukrainian
troops for destroying the city center in
kapians
completely ignoring Russia's role
together
we're in the city center you can hear
the sounds of War yes the ukrainians
have pushed the Russians back but
they've not disappeared people here the
very few that we've spoken to are
clearly terrified the city has been
ruined at the moment and there's no sign
of how long it's going to take until
there's a real sense of Liberation kind
of something coming in
we visited on two consecutive days they
both sounded like this
come on
Russia's markings removed from the local
police station as ukrainians returned to
work despite the danger
the Russians use this place to detain
and potentially torture people
um
the interrogation room now a crime scene
as they collect DNA evidence
a building opposite was also used by the
Russians
the Russian language no
and this was your offices unclear if
this was caused by a Ukrainian or a
Russian strike
one thing's for certain the threat now
is from Russia
so we can hear the sound of incoming
fire now we heard drove a drone noise up
ahead which we were told is the Russians
potentially trying to find positions to
be able to strike
doesn't feel very safe right now
on the edge of the city a semblance of
normality but don't be fooled
um
it's a question all of this country
keeps asking
foreign
Sky News kapiansk